bonsoir nous sommes le 18 mars 2015
bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal de la
rédaction de TVfil 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité des ivelines et dans les
titres le rally des Gazelles les
candidates vont s'élancer ce weekend
depuis Nice et deux participantes
ivlinoises viennent de quitter leur
ville de trappp faire évoluer le regard
sur la trisomi 21 c'est le sens de la
journée mondiale qui se tiendra le 21
mars une occasion de rassembler parents
personnes atteintes chercheurs médecins
et professionnels nous en parlerons avec
notre invité Jacques cosostille le
président de l'Association Française
pour la recherche sur la trisomi 21 et
puis l'élection départementale dimanche
premier tour avant dernier reportage
consacré au candidats sur notre antenne
focus sur le canton de plaisir dans
quelques instants après les radars fixes
place au radar mobile à présent la
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique vient de mettre mettre en
service un second véhicule à radar
automatisé opérationnel dans les
Yvelines depuis le 5 mars il est équipé
d'une antenne placée derrière la plaque
d'immatriculation le flash automatique à
filtre infrarouge ne se voit pas à la
lumière en début de semaine les deux
véhicules ont patrouillé dans le
département ils ont relever plus de 700
véhicules roulant trop vite et nous
constatons au quotidien à travers nos
actions de contrôle que oui la vitesse
moyenne sur les route diminue nous
relevons de moins en moins de grands
excès de vitesse la volonté l'idée c'est
de relever en infraction les gens qui
délibérément vont rouler au-dessus de la
limitation de vitesse en fait quand vous
êtes relevé en infraction on va parler
d'un radar une cabine qui sera implantée
dans une zone à 50 km/h vous allez
recevoir une contravention si vous
roulez au-delà de 56 km/h d'accord avec
ce dispositif vous recevrez une
contravention si vous êtes fâché au-delà
de 61
km/h l'équipe originaire de trappe qui
s'é lance pour le rally des Gazelles
composé donc de Laurence Batala et de
Séverine Soula vous avez déjà pu
apercevoir sur notre antenne était cet
après-midi sur le parvis de la mairie de
trappe pour un dernier au revoir un
moment d'émotion en présence de leur
famille du maire et guimalandin et
d'enfants de 5 à 12 ans des écoles de
trappe elles s'envoleront demain matin
pour Nice où le départ sera donné pour
la compétition le samedi ça fait chaud
au cœur et puis ça fait monter un peu la
pression en se disant que voilà le
départ approche on on est enfin prête
enfin voilà c'est un projet qu'on a
depuis un an et demi donc que ça se
concrétise et donc voilà c'est c'est
vraiment enfin c'est aussi les enfants
avec qui nos enfants sont à l'école et
cetera donc c'est vraiment
impressionnant le 13e festival à Tou
bouchamp a débuté hier à Manil et à Meot
jusqu'au 30 mars de nombreux artistes
vont se produire dans cette commune
certains sont même très jeunes comme ses
élèves de l'école maternelle Coro les
voici durant une répétition 1 2 1 2 3
4 son à moi Anaï
carag avantdernière répétition pour ses
élèves de maternel à Bilé à dans le
cadre du festival à toutout de champ
cette classe prépare son premier concert
coaché par le groupe Debout sur le Zinc
les enfants réalisent chorégraphie et
parole d'une chanson
originale on a travaillé deux chansons
une chanson créée pour par eux et une
autre une autre chanson de de du
spectacle en fait qui joueront en rappel
du du spectacle de debout nous on n
rapporte rien c'est eux qui nous
apportent nous nous on fait on les fait
chanter on essaie de
si on le on le on leur donne une
expérience une petite expérience de de
chanson d'apprendre une chanson ou d'en
écrire et de chant en groupe et de chant
sur scène en
l'occurrence un exercice pas toujours
facile pour les enfants coordonner les
gestes et apprendre les paroles mais
surtout penser au public je comme cel
vous faites et si je fais comme ça vous
faites on va commencer par faire comme
ça vous allez faire
ouais tout ça ça se fait en
musique la représentation est prévue le
20 mars reste àaufiner quelques petits
détails mais dans l'ensemble le
spectacle semble bien
assimilé
bisc
c'est notre
ABCD l'invité de ce soir à présent 21
mars Journée mondiale de la trisomie 21
une journée pour la défense des droits
l'inclusion le bien-être des personnes
qui sont atteintes bonsoir Jacques
Costil et bienvenue vous êtes le
président de l'Association Française
pour la recherche sur la trisomie 21 la
mobilisation va en fait débuter sur
Paris dès le 20 mars ça va se prolonger
jusqu'au 22 mars ensuite la date choisi
du 21 mars en tout cas au niveau mondial
n'est pas anodine elle explique
elleexlicite pardon la présence de trois
chromosomes 2 21 au lieu de 2 d'où le 21
mars 2103 et le but je le disais
sensibiliser est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment déjà d'avoir réussi cette
mission F à mesure des années de
sensibilisation cette cette maladie la
trisomi 21 aujourd'hui est mieux connue
reconnue et bien je pense que oui on
avance même la recherche avance ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que cette date du 21
mars a été iniée par la frt
l'association que je que je préside
actuellement nous étions TR dans un
petit bureau et et ça ça atité en plus
de ça le 21 mars c'est le jour de du
printemps alors voilà tout va bien et et
donc on peut dire que en en 10 ans 2005
2015 on a beaucoup avancé dans
différents domaines que ça soyez
éducatif la prise en charge au niveau SP
Sport est plus plus simple il y a pas
forcément besoin de passer par une
fédération adaptée ou autre les les
clubs acceptent plus facilement les
personnes une meilleure connaissance une
meilleure reconnaissance de la 3 2021
depuis 10 ans 10 ans deob21 et les
handicap la loi de 2005 a aussi amélioré
si tout n'est pas parfait il y aura 3
jours de mobilisation sur sur Paris dans
ce cadre là ça va débuter dès le 20 mars
ce sera à l'École Supérieure
d'Architecture du valde scène donc à
Paris quel va être un peu le programme
alors déjà on fait ça en en partenariat
avec différentes associations l'UNAP
trisomi 21 France les papillons blancs
d'î de France laap 78
reflet 21 de Grenoble AR de de non
reflet 21 de Lyon pardon qui a organisé
l'année dernière et la ris qui
normalement organisera en
2017 puisque nous avons choisi
d'organiser le collec 2016 à Marseille
c'est un choix collégial et donc qui va
se qui
va le vendredi soir c'est plus une forme
d'ouverture par des allocutions et et
différ des différentes personnalités ici
présentes puisque Monsieur Patrick goet
qui a été
délégué au ministère du des personnes
handicapées h euh et euh normalement je
devrais avoir à lire un
un un petit discours de Madame Ségalen n
ville min secrétaire d'État chargé des
personnes handicapées et euh le à partir
du samedi matin on commencera l'é table
ronde C table ronde le but c'est quoi
c'est d'échanger avec des professionnels
c'est que les familles aussi viennent
viennent se renseigner viennent se
rassurer être mieux accompagn aussi le
but c'est que chaque personne qui
présenté chaque intervenant nous fasse
part de son travail auprès des personnes
nées avec une triseire ça soit un
partage avec d'information
et avec le public et il y aura des
questions il y aura des moments de pause
de questions d'échange avec le avec la
salle à se fin que chacun puisse
récolter un maximum d'information et
puisse sur le terrain apporter tout
ça ce sera pendant 3 jours sur sur Paris
c'est la trisomé 21 c'est l'une des
maladies génétique elle est plus commune
est-ce que ça se réduit le nombre de cas
se réduit comment ça évolue il y a
toujours des naissances malgré une
nouveaueste en sénato H il y a encore
des personnes qui passent à côté et des
testes qui qui sont qui donnent négatif
et puis la naissance est positive donc
il y a des nouveaux tests qui sont
apparus à derniè les nouveaux tests des
nouveaux
Teston qui a présidé l'association du 23
ans et une cousine qui a fait tous ces
tests à l'hôpital de BR c'est pas une
mauvaise réputation c'est une très bonne
très bonne hital et et le test était
négatif et pourtant un enfant
trisomié voilà le test à 100 % n'existe
pas pour dépister là aujourd'hui quel
est le combat le combat c'est de réduire
le nombre de naissance de d'enfants qui
sont atteints de trisomi 21 ai justement
votre
combatéer la vie des personnes où je
voulaisenir 60000 personnes c'est c'est
là où je voulais en venir votre combat
c'est d'améliorer ce ce quotidien et
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe ce
combat est-ce que les choses aussi là
s'améliorent pour les personnes qui
vivent avec la maladie avec la alors le
dimanche matin on aura
justement par le professeur de la thorie
le le retour tout un travail dessai
thérapeutique qu'il a mené en Espagne
sur des personnes euh durant 2 ans et
comme je l'ai souvent évoqué ici euh un
composé que l'on trouve dans le thé vert
qui s'appelle le GCG qui agit pour
inhiber la diffusion du gène dir 1A et
donc apparemment ce sont des ces essais
thérapeutiques sont prometteurs et donc
nous à titre afrt on a mené une étude
dernièrement et on n pas encore les les
résultats sur des souris
gestantes ayant UN1 et soigner enfin un
essai
thérapeutique avec cette GCG pour voir
au niveau au moment de la naissance et
après à l'évolution comment s'il y a
modification
de de comportement et du cognitif de de
la souris pour le moment voilà là on en
est là on a déjà on vient de financer
cette étude merci Jacques Costille
président de l'Association Française
pour la recherche sur la triseomi 21
journée mondial donc le 21 mars 2103 et
puis 3 jours à partir du 20 mars sur
Paris de conférence colloque afin de de
trouver comment accompagner afin
d'échanger en tout cas autour de la
maladie merci à vous merci politique
maintenant et coup de projecteur sur les
candidats du canton de plaisir si liste
se présente sur ce secteur les détails
avec michelmido et William H
également le canton de plaisir s'est
agrandi pour ses élections
départementales la commune de Ben a
rejoint les villes de tiveralgrignon des
clés sous-bois et de plaisir le secteur
représente désormais un bassin de vie de
57000 habitants le canton de plaisir est
à gauche depuis les élections
départementales de 2004 et l'élection du
socialiste Jean-Michel Gourdon qui a
choisi de ne pas se représenter le PS
espère conserver sa place à l'Assemblée
départemental pour cela Nicolas Hu
conseiller d'opposition clé sous-bois et
Frédéric Érard plaisir depuis 1999 ont
été désigné par leur parti sur toutes
les
élections nationales ce canton et les
villes principales que sont ben plaisir
et les clés sous-bois votent à gauche
donc nous pouvons penser évidemment que
nous sommes en situation nous pouvons
être en situation favorable après tout
tout tout le résultat sera en fait
fonction de l'abstention et de la
participation pour reconquérir le canton
l'Union de la Droite a mise en place une
équipe composée du duo Joséphine Commens
berger maire UMP de plaisir depuis 2012
et de Bertrand Cocar conseiller
municipal udi des clés sous-bois je
pense que quand on a la chance d'être
élu depuis de nombreuses années on a
effectivement en main en tout
cas une connaissance qui est une
connaissance qui peut qui peut servir à
la population une proximité aussi
puisque c'est un travail que je fais
depuis de nombreuses années d'être
proche de la population à l'écoute avec
je pense du pragmatisme et aussi du
courage politique il en faut donc je
pense qu'au niveau du département je
peux être peut-être utile dans ce duel
annoncé entre le Parti socialiste et
l'Union de la Droite le Front national
va tenter de créer la surprise 3è partie
du canton en 2011 avec 15 % des voix le
FN sera représenté par ériic got et
Estelle de Olivera Fernandez le FN est
devenu la priorité parce que c'est une
autre voie c'est un c'est la politique
sous un autre angle sous une bonne
gestion et nous nous on ne fait pas des
promesses en l'air on tient à bien gérer
les choses quand on tracte on est très
très bien accueilli beaucoup de gens
comptent sur nous parce qu'il commencent
à se rendre compte alors c'est un petit
peu long mais là ça y est je pense que
les gens se rendent compte qu'on leur
ment et que les nos hommes politiques
nos élites ont complètement abandonné
les les les Français et les ivlinois
pour parler plutôt des départementales
mais en fait voilà on a un petit peu
perdu nos hommes politiques dans ce
canton de plaisir trois autres binômes
se présentent le Front de gauche
représenté par le duo maris smier et
Jamel GTI la liste Europe Écologie Les
Verts sera menée par Gérard Levy et
Patricia Charton enfin Fabien meté et
Pascal Michard sont sur la liste de bout
la France lors des dernières élections
de 2011 le socialiste Jean-Michel
Gourdon l'avait emporté devant la
candidate UMP Véronique cotéillard avec
57 % des
voix politique toujours la préfecture
qui vient d'officialiser la date des
élections municipales sur voisin le
Bretonneux vous le savez il va falloir
revoter les élections ayant été annulées
et le premier tour ce sera le dimanche
12 avril ce jeudi aujourd'hui dépôt des
candidatures le point avec Catherine
zulato les élections municipales à
voisin le Bretonneux auront bien lieu
les 12 et 19 avril prochain les
candidatures commencent à se faire
connaître Alexandra rosé timer sortant
udi avait déclaré sur notre antenne dès
l'annonce de l'annulation de l'élection
qu'elle serait un nouveau candidat et
tête de liste Alexis bietle l'ancien
maire battu au second tour qui avait
déposé les deux recours en annulation a
finalement pris sa décision ion il ne
sera pas tête de liste pour ces
nouvelles élections il s'en explique
dans un courrier adressé au vicinois en
déclarant que sa démarche était
désintéressé et que ce n'était pas un
combat personnel il sera toutefois
présent sur une liste emmené par Thierry
gasto son ancien directeur de cabinet
aujourd'hui directeur de cabinet à la
mairie de MPa une troisième liste de
droite pourrait se monter menée par
Olivier Afonso président du conseil de
quartier centre village une quatriè
liste sera proposée par la gauche et le
responsable du groupe d'opposition au
conseil municipal Jean h
les élections municipales avaient été
annulées par le Conseil d'État le 25
février dernier en cause l'écart des 15
voix seulement entre Alexis Biet et
Alexandra Rosetti et la diffusion de
tract le samedi du second tour ce qui
est
interdit le journal revient demain aux
mêmes horaires excellente
soirée